and we're going to bring in a Texas
Democrat Congressman Henry cuer his
congressional district is located along
the southern border you are a huge voice
in all of this sir what is your message
to the White House at this hour knowing
you and fellow your fellow Republican
and Democrat colleagues have penned a
letter to this white house to do
something
you know you got to listen to what's
happening to the communities at the
border the Border communities are asking
for help the men and women in green and
in blue are asking for help so we have
to change something just acting like if
there's everything's okay or the border
is secure which it's not secured we got
to do something we got to work with
Mexico we got to be a little tougher
with Mexico work with other countries
like Guatemala so we can stop up from
coming in but as long as they feel that
the borders open this is not going to
stop
I mean there are some in your your party
who won't even say that they won't even
say that the borders are open and they
are we see people pouring in in record
numbers over our Southern border each
and every day why do you believe the
White House is not listening
you know there are three groups of
people that you need to listen to
immigration activists that's one I
understand that but you also got to
listen to the men and women in green and
blue but you also got to listen
especially to the communities On the
Border I don't I live at the border I
don't just go and visit there I listen
there's not one single mayor County
judge that I know of uh sheriff or
police chief or other landowners are
saying uh everything is fine they are
the we are the ones who are facing this
on ground zero and we just got to make
sure that we do something else besides
acting like the borders closed it's not
closed it's not close Okay so but at
what point did do things have to start
changing here I mean we have men and
women in this Administration that are
assigned to the border to fix what is
happening there and it's only getting
worse at what point do people have to
start losing their jobs
well look we have a lot of career people
that know what needs to be done they do
but they have to be given the
opportunity to do their work uh this is
not a political decision this is
something that has to be decided uh on
the facts and the facts are there's a
lot of people coming in there's a lot of
people waiting on the other side of the
Rio Grande that are waiting for title 42
to go away and you are going to see not
uh thousands you know a small amount of
thousands but you're going to see
thousands and thousands of people that
will be coming over because they're
waiting the criminal organizations are
promoting this because the more people
they come get across the more money they
make so they make money off drugs and
they make money on smuggling and
trafficking people into the United
States and think about what's happening
a migrant all they have to do is just
get to the Texas or the or the U.S
border then after that taxpayers dollars
are used to get them to their point of
uh uh you know where they want to end up
so it's a great deal all they have to do
is just pay for half of the trip and the
other half of the trip will be paid by
American taxpayers
so Congressman you penned this letter a
portion of it reads this never before in
our nation's history have we experienced
this scope and scale of illegal border
crossings and we remain concerned that
your Administration pointing to the
Biden Administration has not provided
sufficient support or resources to DHS
termination of the cdc's title 42 order
at this time will result in a complete
loss of operational control over the
southern border you did not mince words
here sir have you heard anything back
from this White House
I uh I have it I don't think Senator Joe
manchin has I don't think Senator cornyn
I don't think uh my uh good friend Tony
Gonzalez has uh we haven't heard from
them and again uh time is is of the
essence right now there's a way that she
can provide respect and dignity to the
people who are coming to the Border but
at one time another you just got to
enforce the law and uh and if
enforcement the law means deporting some
people that are not supposed to be here
or changing the rules who are Asylum
Seekers can seek Asylum abroad somewhere
or do it in a orally way coming through
our ports of Entry instead of in between
ports there are things that we can do
sending more money for technology for
equipment for personnel all that is
important I understand that but you got
to have the right policies in place I I
just end with this final question
because I'm not sure quite what your
answer was do you have any idea why the
White House is not responding why do
they get it why is the White House house
that you see the drugs you see
terrorists that have been discovered in
in these lines flowing over the Border
you see you see as you just said
taxpayers on the hook once all these
folks get here so why is the White House
doing nothing
well again I'll give you the same answer
I don't know if that's something that
they need to answer all I'm looking at
are the repercussions from inaction uh
from the administration I'm a Democrat I
want to be constructive to the
administration I don't just go and visit
the Border once in a while I live there
I talk to the men and women there and we
and the communities there we have to
have uh some changes without a doubt
come come back once you hear something
from the White House we've seen your
letter you and your colleagues are
putting the urgency this needs on it
thank you very much for joining us
Congressman appreciate it
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else